the Joe Rogan experience hey man what's
up Joe Rogan brother hey I'm alive
you're a lot look man I've been
following this whole everybody's been
following you yeah but first of all tax
should be its own you're very supportive
Joe I mean that means a lot to me I'm
happy to see how healthy yeah yeah you
look good your face looks good yeah thin
hey look you look healthy you look like
you're vibrant yeah no I I'm present I
talked to Dennis he'll and David tell
came to visit me in rehab and he said
you're present you don't want to leave
every five seconds yeah which is what
cocaine does to you right you know so no
I feel good I feel good I mean it's I
got nine months clean that's amazing
yeah that's amazing two days ago was
what's the hump like what do they say
you have to get over before you can stay
clean well first of all my drug history
is insane its it started when the first
time I got high and I tell these young
kids cuz you know I'm 52 now so I was in
you know I was in rehab and jail and a
halfway house the last eight months and
with some of the craziest [ __ ]
you've ever met in your life and they
all have stories but once they know my
story because I had some success in life
basically as a full-blown junkie they're
fascinated by it right and the first
time I got high was 1979 okay Jimmy
Jimmy Carter was president so when you
tell a 22 year old kid that they're like
blown away that I'm even alive and I am
- I was I I hit a homerun in Little
League I'll never forget this and I my
buddy's older brother was to call this
kids sick Jack I don't know what
happened to him but he he had the me a
joint and I took a puff on a weed and
from 11 years old I knew I loved it so
much I just loved B I love the feeling
of being out of control you talked to a
normal person they go
I hate being out of control I loved it I
loved like wow and you have an excuse
for it I was [ __ ] up yeah that's the
thing yeah as use for being wild an
excuse for just being a screw-up too you
know and
our man was a lunatic he was not a drug
addict or an alcoholic but he was a
criminal you know he was a low-level
criminal he came here the streets in
Newark and got to like the tenth grade
in high school and he was like my
favorite human being of all time he was
like my older brother but I saw him do a
lot of bad [ __ ] you know I saw him fight
all the time he was a boxer when he was
young and just the real street smart guy
and his life was chaos and I love the
chaos I was addicted to risk that's why
I'm a gambler too so
when cocaine came into my life a few
years later I was 16 the first time I
did a line a blow and that was really
fun because now you're up all the time
and and that started basically a 35-year
drug run that didn't end the like nine
months ago I mean I don't know if it's
ended you know that's the thing I don't
put pressure on myself I'm like it's one
that one day at a time stuff it sounds
so cliche but I take it one minute at a
time
I can't guarantee people I'm never gonna
get I again I just know I'm not gonna
get high to next ten minutes and I don't
want again there is your risk of saying
that you don't know if you're ever gonna
get high again uh like you know well the
direct opposite is true that's what they
tell you in a program like Narcotics
Anonymous and again I'm not some big
program guy turn to some God guy
anything like that but I'm a little more
spiritual I would say and you know it's
all stuff you know used to tell me the
last time I was on the show you know
you're telling me to travel afraid like
you know exercise anything anything that
gets you through today that's positive
you know I in other words by saying
you'll never get high again and I used
to do that all the time when you really
[ __ ] in yourself and everybody else
you put a lot of pressure on yourself
you know like to say even these young
kids these poor kids man are looking at
a lot of jail time prison time that
living under a [ __ ] bridge some of
these kids and they got nothing that's
why you know the careers of me and you
have and congratulations on your
everything you've done Joe man you just
couldn't you're a solid guy a great
talent but um you know I the careers we
have are such blessing
I mean we're living out a dream you know
and these kids have nothing and for a 23
year old kid to say in a in a group
therapy session anywhere I'm never gonna
get high again did one thing to say
you're never gonna do anything again and
even for me at 52 years old
I love it you got to say I love I love
being high I love the chaos I love the
lifestyle you get addicted to the
lifestyle too cuz you live like you
don't live like everybody else you know
and I had a means of making money
legally and you know these kids had a
Rob to get all the [ __ ] and and so that
was enabling - we live in an enabling
world but uh to say you're never gonna
get high again is so much pressure to
say I don't know and just work on the
next day and for me it's like I take it
minute by minute literally I got high at
like we're here on the Lower East Side
of Manhattan right now I got high
everywhere here back in the 80s I used
to come here and my my buddies older
brother and get mescaline hits ludes
back in a day you know we in Washington
Square Park blow
so there's triggers all over the place
so I just say if I can get this one more
just get one more block without [ __ ]
out that turns into a day and in time
you know so it's it's harder to say for
yourself I I'll never get high again
[Applause]